now for the big quiz in all seriousness
this is the most complicated exercise
I've given you so far this lesson I want
you to implement the details view using
the cursorloader
and multiple text view widgets and I've
got some hints for you use loaders not
adapters what does this mean well it
makes sense your detailed view does not
contain a list so you don't need to use
an adapter but you can still use the
loader pattern the loader pattern will
automatically observe for changes in the
URI with a cursor loader the second
thing you want to do is pass the date
into your intent the date is the
important thing that the detail of you
needs to have passed into it to properly
query the content provider now remember
you can actually get the current
location settings from the utility
function so all you really need is the
date I hope that helps